okay okay don't panic don't panic oh my  gosh a panicky what do I do  I'm out of toilet paper I have a poopy  butt right now I have a poopy ball get  it together get it together what are we  gonna do okay Zach think think there's  napkins in the kitchen pull up your  pants and waddle to the kitchen and get  yourself some napkins you've got this  oh hey Zack hey I want you to meet my  friend Kelsey hi hey how's it going I've  heard so much about you umm I would  shake your hand but I'm feeling a little  under the weather I'm sick right now so  oh yeah yeah fine cool um I'll let you  guys just be I'm gonna be back in my  bedroom nice meeting you all right cool  uh see you later nice to meet you